kelly gens parlent jamais de sa star
boudou salue sa base de tubes et non pas
une bonne stage me mets ça de valium
formé chez rigoler ça veut dire le mec
qui va sortir avec kelly ont décrit une
petite blonde avec une moustache la
matza sans rigoler ne cherchez plus à
prôner la pour le prochain astérix
on peut être magnifique quelques
moustache
oui mais les femmes ont autant de poils
que les hommes ne se voient pas c'est
exactement la même chose vous ai pas
parlé tout à l'heure
j'adorerais mais c'est vrai la raison
les femmes ou retombent pas le cas
d'hommes ils sortent eux - les races
comme on sait qu a déjà vu des meufs qui
sera this toi et toi ne veulent pas
sortir de chez les mavs qui disent non
on est bien on sort pas repasser dans
une heure peut-être mais n'ont certes
pas que de la finale a pas un poil sur
le caillou
[Rires]
delphine c'est bon d'être lancé mais oui
nous imaginaient banon mais pas du tout
mes arrière assez bon héros et qu'il
existe quelques produits alors on va
rappeler que vous avez un bac vous avez
fait un bac es et tu te reste ici voilà
exactement jackson éthique mais vous
avez raison d'assumer et il existe des
produits qui font apparaître ses poils
qu'on ne voit pas à l'oeil nu
non non non non si t'as pas beaucoup de
sources il fumait un produit qui va
faire apparaître des femmes à poil que
les femmes du produit moche on les
appelait temps elle a fait des études 7
6 ah ouais bravo ben ça n'a pas beaucoup
ces maisons en enlever de temps en temps
les couper je sais jamais sur les
planches comme serait elle décolle enfin
ses pieds soit faut les couper et vous
rêvez vous serez volée et j'aurais pu et
je le dis pour votre examen
non vous étiez dans une première
instance vient d'embaucher un entretien
d'embauché
et qu'est ce qu'elle vous a ffaires la
jeune âge et ma patronne qui s'est mis
sur le lit qui s'est mis comme ça pour
écarter ses fesses et j'ai dû lui epinay
la clé à l'école et j'étais un petit peu
démuni suis dit comment on fait la
patronne du cul voilà quoi mais gardons
pas pour un entretien dans l'écouté
balle à elle met les gens à l'aise
on m'a expliqué le sens du poil de
l'anus et maintenant moi je connais si
je peux paraître c'est un très très beau
début de
vraiment très très dur
[Applaudissements]